can we go to the big picture of the
criminal justice system what to you
given the ideal works about our criminal
justice system
and what is broken
well there's a lot broken uh right right
now and i usually focus on
on that uh but uh in truth a lot
uh works about our criminal justice
system so there's a there's an old joke
uh and it uh it it's funny
but it it carries a lot of truth to it
and the joke is that um in the united
states we have the
worst criminal justice system
in the world except for every place else
yeah
and uh and yes we certainly have a
number of problems uh
and a lot of problems based on race and
class
and economic station but we have a
process that privileges the liberty and
that's a
good feature of the criminal justice
system
so here's how it works the idea of the
relationship between the individual and
the state
is such that in the united states
we privilege liberty over and above
very many values so much so that a
statement by
increased mather not you know terribly
far from where we're sitting
right now has gained traction uh over
all these years and it's that better
10 guilty go free than one innocent
person convicted
that is an expression of the way in
which
uh we understand liberty to operate in
our collective
consciousness we would rather a bunch of
guilty people go
free than to than to um
impact the liberty interests of any uh
individual person
so that's a guiding principle in our
criminal justice
system uh liberty and so we set
a process that makes it difficult
to convict people we have rules of
procedure
that are cumbersome and that slow down
the process
and that um exclude otherwise reliable
evidence and this is all because we
place a value
on uh liberty and i think these are good
things and it
uh and it says a lot about our criminal
justice system
some of the bad features have to do with
the way in which
uh uh this country sees color as a proxy
for
criminality and and treats uh people of
color in radically different ways in the
in the criminal justice system
uh from uh arrests to uh
charging decisions to sentencing um
people of color are disproportionately
impacted
uh on all sorts of registers um
one example and it's a popular one
that uh although there appears to be
no uh distinguishable difference between
uh drug use by whites and blacks
in the country um uh blacks though
only 12 of the population represent 40
percent
of the uh the drug charges in
in the country there's there's there's
some disequities
along race and class and the criminal
justice system that we
really have to have to have to fix
and they've grown to more than than
bugs in the system and have become
features unfortunately
of our system oh to to make it more
efficient to make judgments
so the racism makes it more efficient it
uh it it efficiently
uh moves people uh from society to the
streets
uh and that's uh um
and a lot of innocent people get caught
up in that
you